plenty of other topics though still
hovering over the nfl and one the
availability this weekend or next
weekend or the weekend after that of
chiefs quarterback patrick mahomes he
did not play on sunday night when the
chiefs lost to the packers chiefs are
now five and three on the year and owen
won without patrick mahomes mahomes had
told michelle tafoya of nbc before the
game that it was a playoff game he would
have played andy reid the coach of the
chiefs chimed in on this and he says
that basically it's going to come down
to what the doctors say
he reid said that mahomes during the
denver game was trying to get back in
after he had the dislocated kneecap so
mahomes wants a play and the chiefs like
that about him but ultimately it's what
the doctors think now here's the thing
to keep in mind at the risk of being
ultracynical but we know how this works
the doctors are paid by the team they
are hired by the team
and if the doctors want to continue to
be hired by the team and work for the
team and it is a very lucrative
assignment in the market where the
doctors are because
if you are providing medical care to the
local nfl team the average person is
going to assume that that must be a good
doctor so you use that to leverage a
bigger practice you make more money and
that's what capitalism's all about
so a key to that is retaining the
relationship with the local nfl team and
one key to retaining the relationship is
sometimes you got to tell them what they
want to hear
so it's not
it's not
laboratory settings it's not determined
in a vacuum
and sometimes the
the doctors and i'm not saying this is
what's going on here we just have to
recognize the bias sometimes the doctors
are listening for those clues
regarding
what they think
the patient or the person footing the
bill wants to hear and in a case like
this when the patient wants to play
you know you almost have to be careful
you don't push back too hard if you're
the doctors because the team may
ultimately say well
if the guy can play then just let him
play we're willing to take some risk if
he's willing to take some risk but
that's ultimately the decision the
chiefs have to make if they do want to
nudge the doctors or not nudge the
doctors if they just want to be ultra
safe maybe what they do in a case like
this is they nudge the doctors towards
saying he can't play so then patrick
mahomes won't get mad at the team won't
get mad at the coach for not letting him
play so you know the pressure can go
both ways
and in the old days the pressure was
always along the lines of pushing the
player
and the team to get the guy on the field
because that's what the coach wanted
now in a case like this who knows maybe
the chiefs are trying to tap the brakes
a little bit on getting mahomes back on
the field because they understand the
risk that they would be taking by
putting their most important player on
the field prematurely and potentially
getting him injured
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports